In two decades of practicing medicine,
I've encountered a wide number
of medical diagnoses.
You see, it turns out that there are more
than 60,000 different medical diagnoses
that you can list on a patient's chart.
You can actually be diagnosed
with a burn injury
when your water skis catch on fire.
There are also codes if you need
surgery after being bitten by a pig,
(Laughter)
hit by a spacecraft,
stabbed while crocheting,
or my favorite,
due to extreme problems with your in-laws.
(Laughter)
But the best of all has got to be the code
for getting sucked into a jet engine.
And the reason that I like this one
is because this is not the code
for the first time this happens,
but for the subsequent encounter.
(Laughter)
So there must be people on this Earth
that have been sucked
into a jet engine twice.
(Laughter)
But I think, you know, kidding aside,
we have to recognize
that every last one of us in this room
is most likely to die
of only one of two diagnoses.
And these, of course, are either cancer
or cardiovascular disease.
This speaks to the incredible
public health importance
of these two diseases
and the urgent, unmet medical need
to develop new therapies
directed against them.
A lot of people are not surprised
that these two diseases
claimed so many lives.
After all, they are very
different biologically,
they have different risk factors,
and they affect very different
patient populations.
But for the next 15 minutes or so,
I would like to propose
a different hypothesis.
That perhaps they actually have
quite a lot in common.
And even more importantly,
I would like to suggest
that if we think about them this way,
we might be able to develop new therapies
that could treat both diseases
at the same time.
So before I tell you
why I believe this hypothesis,
let me lay out the counter
arguments against it.
I think many people would say
that the old man who smokes
cigarettes his whole life
and has a heart attack
shares very little in common
with a young person
who develops colon cancer out of the blue.
But we now know that the risk factors
for these diseases
have significant overlap.
And the things that cause one disease
can also put you at risk for the other.
Well, that may be true,
but we know that genetically
these diseases couldn't be more different.
I'm sure many of you have heard
about these cancer genes
that can be mutated in families
that could put both mother
and daughter at risk for breast cancer.
We know that those genes
have nothing to do with heart attack,
and that's true also.
But I would point out that those genes
were discovered decades ago,
before the Human Genome Project
and before we could scan all three billion
base pairs at the same time.
And when we do this
for patients having heart attack,
we find that the top hotspot
for having a heart attack
is located on chromosome nine,
shown here with these blue dots.
And what shocked the world
when this paper was first published
was that this genetic locus
has nothing to do with smoking
or cholesterol or diabetes.
But actually seems to control
a well-known cancer gene
that's mutated in patients
with melanoma, brain cancer,
lung cancer, etc.
And so for decades,
we've been focusing on the traditional
cardiac risk factors.
But the genetics now tell us
that the most important factor
may actually have to do
with a well-known cancer gene instead.
Well, that's an interesting observation,
but we know that if you look
under the microscope
at these two diseases,
they couldn't be more different.
When I was in medical school,
I was taught that cancer is really
just about cells dividing too quickly.
And you can imagine this lung tumor
growing over time
and taking over the lung,
and that this has nothing to do
with what happens in heart disease,
which is a problem that, I was taught,
was due to the buildup of cholesterol
that can ultimately lead
to the blockage of an artery
and a heart attack or a stroke.
And to be sure, both of these biological
processes are critically important.
But I would point out that the modern-day
textbook of these diseases
is getting harder and harder
to tell apart.
We now know that both
of these conditions are dominated
by the influx of inflammatory cells
and immune cells
and abnormal blood vessels
and even stem cells.
And so maybe the textbooks
that I used are out of date.
Well, at this point, you might say
these are interesting observations,
but is there any clinical data
which would suggest
that patients with one disease
are actually at higher risk of the other?
Turns out that investigators,
both in Asia and Europe,
have now started to test this hypothesis.
And just last year,
a very important article
was published out of Germany,
where they looked at more
than 100,000 individuals
with congestive heart failure
and they found that these people
were at much higher risk
of developing cancer.
This is really interesting
and suggests to me
that indeed having one disease
may put you at risk of the other.
But this also raises a very
important scientific principle
that association is not
the same as causation.
And if you wanted to test that hypothesis,
you would have to do an experiment
where you took a healthy individual
and then intentionally
gave them a heart attack.
You'd have to let some time go by
to see what changes occur
throughout the body.
And then you could determine
if their rate of cancer was higher
or vice versa, if their rate
of heart disease was higher.
Now, obviously, we can't do this type
of an experiment in human beings.
This would be unethical.
But this type of an experiment
is done in research laboratories
every day around the world
in mouse models of human disease.
Just last year, two very
important studies were published
where investigators took healthy mice
and then implanted small tumors
underneath their skin.
They looked at the rate at which
these cancers would grow over time.
And what they found in both studies
was that the mice who had heart disease
had much higher rates of cancer.
And what was fascinating to me
was that they were able
to confirm these findings
across a wide range of tumors,
suggesting to me that really
the presence of heart disease
is sufficient to accelerate cancer growth.
So having heard all this,
the natural question is whether
we can do anything about this.
So outside of my work at Stanford,
one of my volunteer roles
is with the American Heart Association.
And one of our public health initiatives
is called Life’s Simple Seven.
We try to get patients
with a history of heart disease
to control these very simple
and straightforward risk factors
like exercise, cholesterol and diet.
The idea here is
that if you can control these,
you should be able to lower your risk
of having additional
cardiovascular events.
This is now pretty widely accepted.
But what's fascinating to me
is that a group of investigators
have now looked at the association
with these risk factors and cancer.
And in a study with more
than 10,000 individuals
who were followed for almost two decades,
they found the people
who had optimal control
of all their risk factors
had a pretty low rate
of developing cancer.
But for each risk factor
which fell out of control,
the risk of malignancy went up.
And you can see that the group who had
poor control of all seven risk factors
had by far the highest rates of cancer,
with nearly a doubling of the risk.
So this suggests to me that,
in fact, if we want to control cancer,
we might start by controlling
our cardiac risk profile.
So this is fine and we continue
to encourage our patients to do this.
But the reality is that even
if I had a magic wand
and could somehow optimally control
everybody's risk factors,
we know that we would still be dealing
with both the number one
and number two causes of death worldwide.
This tells us that we need
to find new therapies
that could treat or even prevent
these conditions in the first place.
Now our laboratory chooses to do this
with an unbiased genetics approach.
We take biopsies from patients
with or without a wide variety of tumors,
or with and without
cardiovascular disease.
And instead of looking
at one gene at a time,
we scan the whole genome and look
at the expression of all 20,000 genes.
You can plot these on a plot like this
where each gray dot
represents its own gene.
And when you acquire enough samples,
you can begin to identify
patterns of those genes
which are bad for cancer
versus those that protect against it.
And do the same type of an experiment
to find those things that will accelerate
or prevent against cardiovascular disease.
Now, I think the clever part
of this approach
is to integrate these
and to run these analyses simultaneously.
When you do this, we can begin to look
at factors in the red quadrant.
These are genes
that we suspect should be bad
for both heart disease disease and cancer
and must be avoided at all costs.
Or even better,
perhaps we can find factors
in the blue quadrant
that should be able to protect
against both diseases.
We hypothesize that those factors
in the blue quadrant could be prioritized
to help us find new medicines
to cure these two leading killers.
Now our group has run these analyses
on several thousand individuals.
This work is still underway,
but so far we've identified a list
of about three dozen pathways
that we do think should be prioritized.
Now, time will tell if these work.
If all of them work, if some,
if any of them work.
We just don't know.
But I do want to show you
a couple of examples
that would suggest
that we're on the right path.
In the red quadrant, one of the factors
we found relates to inflammation.
And we often think
of inflammation as being bad,
but in reality, this is a process
that our body evolved
to help us recover from injury
or to mount a fever
to fight off an infection.
But of course, there are always times
where our body has too much of something.
In this case,
there's a rare genetic syndrome
where children can be born
with overactive inflammation,
and they can have recurrent episodes
of high fevers and rashes
and other neurocognitive
and developmental delays.
Now in a triumph of science,
investigators have pinpointed
the exact molecule responsible for this,
and they developed a drug
that can block it.
These children who have these rashes
that I mentioned before
can have a relatively remarkable
improvement on these drugs
and almost get back
to a normal quality of life.
But relevant to today's talk,
it turns out that there are
a group of cardiologists
who, for decades, have hypothesized
that these same inflammatory factors
may also be driving heart disease.
They were able to convince the company
that makes this drug
to do a trial to look
at the effect of this medicine
in patients who had had a heart attack
or a stroke in the past.
And really, it was
no surprise to many of us
when the results of this trial
were published.
And they showed that, in fact,
compared to a placebo,
that this medicine could prevent
recurrent cardiovascular events.
But our algorithms predict that this drug
should not only help
prevent heart disease
but also should be able to prevent cancer.
And so this particular article
gained a lot of attention
because when they unblinded their results,
the investigators were shocked to find
that not only were the patients
having fewer heart attacks
but they were having a much lower rate
of developing lung cancer
and a much lower rate
of even dying from cancer.
In fact, these results
were so surprising and powerful
that I understand the company
that makes this drug
is now pivoting and prioritizing
this as a cancer drug,
because the effects were so significant.
How about another example
from the blue quadrant this time?
Well, here we come to one
of my favorite cells in the body,
which is an immune cell
called the macrophage.
Now, macrophage is from the Greek,
meaning "big eater."
And the role of this cell
is to patrol the body,
like a sentinel,
and it looks for invading bacteria.
When it sees them,
it actually will eat them
and remove them from our body
before they can expand
and cause an infection.
But just like in the last example,
there are oncologists
who have hypothesized
that these macrophages
don't just have to eat bacteria,
but they also have to look for
and eat cancer cells
and hopefully get rid of them
before they can grow
and metastasize.
And so there's been a major initiative
to develop medicines
that can increase
the appetite of these cells
to help them go after those tumors.
Now, this story is still
in its early days,
and it's unclear if this type
of an approach will work.
But some of the early
studies would suggest
that patients who have
metastatic lymphoma,
which you can see spread throughout
this person's body on their CAT scan,
that they may have a remarkable response
to these types of drugs.
And you can imagine here
that the tumors are melting away
as they're being eaten by these cells
due to their increased appetite.
But once again, what we found
is that our algorithms predict
that, yes, this drug
should work for cancer,
but we think it might also
work for heart disease.
And so we've now gone back
and retrospectively analyzed
the same CAT scans
from the same cancer patients.
But this time, instead of looking
at the signal from their tumors,
we can look at the signal
in their blood vessels.
And here I'm pointing with the arrow
to the carotid artery.
This is the artery
that brings the blood to the brain,
this is where cardiovascular
disease will build up
in patients before they have a stroke.
And what we found is that while
their cancer was melting away,
it looks like their cardiovascular disease
was melting away, too.
And so, once again,
these algorithms are predicting
that we may be able to identify therapies
that could be dual purposed to attack
both conditions at the same time.
We don't yet know if any
of these other pathways
will have the same type of success.
But what we do know for sure is the lesson
that Galileo taught us
almost four centuries ago,
and that there is no such thing
as settled science.
We must challenge dogma,
we must break down traditional silos.
Because if we do,
we may no longer be powerless
against these leading killers,
but may, in fact find ways to treat
the world's two leading killers.
Thank you.
(Applause)